well we don't need another reason to
adore aina garten the barefoot contessa
my favorite
you know whenever anyone asked me like
the celebrity that i've never met who
i've always wanted to meet i always say
her i just love her
because she reminds me of my mom the
same haircut and she cooks like my mom i
just love you
well insider reports that in a garden
turns out she's just like us she's got
her own self-doubts you guys in fact she
just revealed that she says she's not a
very confident cook
i know aina gar the barefoot contessa
what well despite being one of the most
famous chefs on planet earth and our
favorite she says that cooking is really
hard even when she's making dinner for
like four people she says to herself how
is this going to happen which i have to
say makes me feel better about all the
kitchen disasters i've had in my life
she says her insecurities come from
never having been formally trained and i
think that you and i can both relate
because both of us love to get in the
kitchen but we didn't i didn't go to
culinary school you've done some classes
right didn't you go to i've done some
classes and i i i'm an amateur humble
home cook but i i i i don't relate to
her in the kitchen i relate to her like
at work in general how do you mean well
i'm not a chef so i'm not going to even
pretend to relate to her there i just
think like oh wow that's really
refreshing to hear that
i think we all go through you know just
such inner voices that we have to kind
of
figure out how to master they're not
doing us many favors a lot of the time
and it's sort of like maybe it's like
this thing that's there to test us to
help us evolve and grow strong and
figure out how to
find that confidence and you just look
at someone like her and she ironically
seems so effortless yeah so i'm like oh
my gosh if she struggles too like maybe
we're not all so crazy and it's a big
part of the journey of life because
sometimes i'm like it is so crazy in
here that to hear aina garten struggle
sometimes i'm like oh okay well maybe we
all do yeah yeah if someone like who's
as good as what she does as she is can
have those self-doubt so maybe we should
cut ourselves a little slack every now
and then right why did you say it so
much better so much quicker because i
heard you say it first
well
some people travel with their kids and
some bring their dogs and now you can
bring your plants
apartment therapy reports the elwood
hotel and suites in lexington kentucky
is the first plant-friendly hotel
that's right plant lovers can check in
with their fern no questions asked and
enjoy the gardener's premier corner room
a lush suite decked out with plenty of
plants plus a succulent souvenir to take
home apparently the greenery starts in
the lobby where there's a giant fiddle
leaf fig and if you know what that is
then it might excite you
yeah so i mean i i thought plants like
to stay where they were i didn't know
they like to travel
i got a real fussy plant at home yeah
maybe i should take her there take her
on a road trip maybe i you know i'm just
going to leave this one alone thank you
i can't
no
you
if i did yes i did
oh yes you did
well i'm all about it i'd love to check
out this hotel
you think i i i would there's a lot of
weird gimmicks out in the world this one
seems real harmless and sweet
yeah i'm go i'm good i'll be down at the
hilton
[Music]
you